good morning Millennials good morning
counselor Smith good morning camper
countersuit I'm so excited you're you're
hosting with me today I missed you so
much
but I understand that you're so busy so
busy are you maybe in counselor in
camber the whole the whole episode not
the whole episode because I will spend
some time as the American camper but I'm
also the Italian counsel aorta sneetches
welcome to my shows our first time
meeting I'm so excited to meet you
counsel you on ice me just what do i
back for this camp
seriously why can't the Italian cat she
can't be that just shorts and a t-shirt
guys it's not hard she can't figure out
what to pack for this camp it's really
not so hard like she's never been to
camp before I don't think she's gonna be
your favorite camper no maybe not I am
so excited for camp and I'm excited to
me my favorite counselor counsel the
oddest features you should meet the
American camber I think you guys were
getting along great this American camper
she is very weird
she's the weird one yeah counselors
Mitch I heard what the Italian campers
said about me and you know what I think
we can really hash it out over some
gelato because I don't want you to have
any drama in your bunk this summer thank
you
as a shape that for the record Jackie
Tyler there was a surprise on the show
today and that was it but I guessed it
right before we she did right before we
went live so I'll be going in and out of
characters all show long it'll be really
fun for the podcast listeners and I just
felt like finally you needed to meet the
Italian camp yeah took time you also did
kind of look like a driver but like it's
good well the Italian camera obviously
she has a part-time job does she yeah
but a Mac she is an issues hustler but
American camper doesn't know how to
drive so right now it's true that's why
she tubers yeah American camera takes a
lot of ubers counts so sisters have
right because no one else could watch
her yesterday
anyways welcome to the show I'm so
excited that you're here my favorite
counselor counselor snitch
welcome it's been a while I know I was
just thinking about that one was last
time that I was here um lost kegs was
that it was it we everywhere misses
Wow the significance of a hat is just I
had no clue the Hat can really be so
transforming it really is it really is
it really is any way that I know to see
what I look like with one of these hats
I've never worn one in my life and I
feel like I would look psychotic oh no
you look so cute like even like that did
Danielle mbar just walk onto the show
where am i yes I think now we have a man
standing it out I've to wait for the
feature fries to see if I look good so
yeah I'll be like this for a little bit
you don't look like a driver we
recommend a new look now because we
struggle with the top of my head
honestly
perhaps okay look you're about to put it
on them okay weenies like get into the
show sorry sorry guys sorry oh my god I
love it
come on it's good I'm Italian camber
foods I American cameras gonna freak out
I know just don't tell her but she
doesn't know won't hurt her she'll find
out cuz she has access to the Internet
and she can watch a show she definitely
like it on the internet all the time
like on YouTube watching Jojo see Wow
yeah like just watching every like you
to bursting she like does her she learns
thank God stop she makes me sad American
camera at least Italian Kamber it's like
right no her [ __ ] don't stink she's out
here in the streets of Italy she an uber
driver just trying to figure out what
too bad I can't I'll send her packing
guys huh oh my god you guys I'm so sorry
I hope you're enjoying this but I hope
you understand that at least this is
just the toast cotton road we've gone
off the rails immediately okay I had a
feeling good that's what happened I said
to Jackie I was like are you gonna be
okay doing the pole show with counselor
snitch I'm not okay but it is my job to
put the show on the rails so I'm gonna
bury I'm sorry towards the end we could
even get back into it we can snitch out
because I just have to and then if
you're not interested you can leave if
you're really just here for the news
because you just won't know what's going
on in the world if we don't tell you
then this is for you
so welcome to the show how is life you
just started school this week I did just
start school this week and it's like I
just can't wait for it to be over
because I hate it and that's that I hate
school how are your classes this
master um stupid I'm actually action
taking some interesting ones the art and
science of parenting maybe I'll learn to
be a better counselor that's impossible
sir already the best counselor right and
my favorite one at that right and then
there's a weird-ass class I know it's
just like one of those stupid ones that
I have to take and then there's this
other class that like I have to learn
how to like do excel like legit you know
which is a probably a good life skill
but I can't figure it out so if anyone's
really good at it just let me know okay
TBD anyways you know I have a countdown
going speaking of CAP forwards right
graduate but speaking of countdowns
I finished dry January Mazel Tov it's
really been so [ __ ] annoying for me
because we've had all these like major
nights out he had just two major nights
out that's a lot yet it was one weekend
and you you were fun don't get me wrong
but you could have been funner for sure
but I was really fun yes yes specially
first Oberstein asked me an especially
for the fact that you stayed out till
4:00 a.m. I'm sober like you couldn't
pay me no but honestly the first night
the joke of mrs. hat was making me drunk
no I like I was drunk
honestly the first night I really didn't
even like drink that much like I didn't
because it's like I was having so much
fun at lost kings and it was like I
don't want to hinder myself by having a
drink in my hand right you know ting I
didn't like spilling on you know your
sisters coat your sister's shoes and I
didn't spill and I just stepped agging
all your sister's clothes snagging all
my sister's clothes yeah sorry
so I was drunk on hat and you know this
is that wasn't the first time in and it
will be the last time that a hat just
gets me going so anyways I still have
haven't had a drink yet we were gonna go
to like dinner last night
it really just didn't work out but what
I did do last night is I went over to
Olivia and Zach's they gave me a home
tour that was so robust and so good and
I really owe it I always knew that like
they had a nice apartment yeah they're
moving on up um but really it's just
like now that I was going through every
nook and cranny and looking at brie tile
and wallpaper in the bathrooms like it
made me like green with envy I only saw
the second half of the video because
that was like a direct link you know
uh-huh
and her bathroom that tub I was like I
just feel like I'll never be the kind of
person who gets that plate to that place
in their life where they're gonna have a
bathtub like that but you step up a
bidet I don't even use it I love
today I didn't even know they had the
days like for available for rentals in
New York City right so it just made me
rethink stuff and I wasn't planning on
like moving out of my apartment even
though my lease is up soon but now like
I remember it
I'm so over it oh where do you want to
move like move on up I want to move into
Olivia's apartment okay so anyways they
should buy that apartment they don't
know if they can but if you want to
check out her swanky ass pad patreon.com
Sasha morning toast and then we did
something serious because there were so
many questions cuz people knew we were
doing the Home Tour and so we did a mini
podcast episode of 20 minute podcast I
just loved like a mini podcast and asked
them all their questions and they were
being like so sweet it was so cute it
made me so excited for marriage so that
I can go back to being sweet and stop
being a savage this is what I am right
now
I am a full-on salad I like savage
Jackie I know but it's just like there's
no holding back
this isn't I mean I was never this way
before and I don't know if I can go back
there you can go back because you have
nothing to like once it's over you have
nothing to be savage about I know but
like it's like this savage the Beast has
come out oh babe can she be tamed maybe
she'll go into hibernation until like
the next big thing okay but anyways it's
basically you have that side of you when
you need it
they were being really yes exactly they
were being really cute and sweet and it
was it was a really nice episode so you
get two videos and a podcast episode
okay check on Sasha morning toast and
then Claudia Ben also did patreon where
they took one of those quizzes that
tells you here are sociopath sociopath
is that what those quizzes are I thought
it was one of those ones that it's like
those personality tests and I tell you
what you're supposed to do or what
you're supposed to be or something like
that no I thought no but no I think it
might be right to do something about
numbers yeah mine wasn't numbers so I
started I have to finish exciting I need
to find out what she is cuz apparently I
think it's like crazy I everything I
know the number that she has but I
remember you you don't know what it
means no no don't ruin it for me I'm
gonna get back to alright
anyways anyways now we are here you and
I I am no longer needing to be sober so
this weekend well party it up are we
partying yeah well we'll have we'll
drink that well at the Super Bowl party
at this thing looks like drink beers and
like enjoy our lives I'm gonna have a
wine oh but I don't have an outfit yet I
bought a hat because I'm like fat
I bought a hat the power of a hat
because like I'm not last year I wore
Jersey
I'm Patriots lost this year wear a hat
maybe they'll would and you're mrs. hat
so you have to write I'm pretty Super
Bowl agnostic this year meaning what
meaning I'm not Rudy I'm rooting for the
Patriots like in my heart and aunt like
when I'm watching me like oh yeah
hopefully Patriots but I'm not gonna go
as far it's like we're Patriots gruyère
and like post a picture and be like Pat
season I might I just like write you
love them I love them I'm cool with I
just like but like merely because I
think they're all so hot like that's how
I judge and because I've made the call
100 times but people try and steal it
that Patriots are the Kardashians of
football and it's still true it's like
everyone hates them but then everyone
loves to hate them you know and they
always succeed just saying they're you
there so anyways we'll drink tomorrow or
Sunday I mean no rush okay but I will be
drinking and I just want to say my
overall conclusion on try January's
never felt worse in my life mentally and
physically so um no need so good
actually just wrote about that in tipsy
toasters the the drinking toasters group
she was like I completed shower January
and I haven't lost one pound in the
bloat has still remained so I don't I
haven't lost one pound since the ending
of Jan maybe I've lost one pound because
I've been working out a lot but that
also gains muscles so now I'm pretty
much like gaining now um yeah my skin is
like not great
nothing's great I mean my spirit isn't
great yeah so spirit yeah anyways are
you ready now I'm ready I'm gonna
actually don't know any news that has
happened today or yesterday so fill me
in are you ready to get into the past
I've stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast yeah yes you are
just loving this hat on you me too is I
think it's I can't stop looking at
myself and it's like pay attention Margo
you're on candid camera and it's like
they don't call you mrs. hat for no
reason I know next time we hit the clubs
with los Kings you've gotta wear that
hat is there gonna be a next time I hope
so I hope so just for the sheer fact
that it was so fun I knows so fun and
they're actually really good DJ it's
like they're good at their job it's not
baked agreed okay
first story just an update in the polar
vortex that is legitimately sweeping the
nation the poor lobe
the polar vortex death toll raises to 21
as US cold snap continues at least 21
people have died in one of the worst
cold snaps to hit the u.s. Midwest in
decades 90 million people a third of the
US have seen temperatures of a negative
17 Celsius zero degrees Fahrenheit or
below some 250 million Americans overall
have experienced the polar vortex
conditions hospitals have been treating
patients reporting frostbite as parts of
the country ground to a halt
temperatures are expected to swing to
above average over the weekend who are
the victims homeless people have been
particularly at risk with warming
shelters set up across cities but some
still braved the freezing conditions in
one woman each 60 was found dead in an
abandoned house in Lorraine I awho a
hospital in Chicago has already treated
50 patients for frostbite and some may
end up losing a limb CNN reports half of
those patients were homeless individuals
while others had jobs that required them
to be outdoors some people were found
dead a short walk from their house a
Michigan man who froze to death in his
neighborhood had been quote inadequately
inadequately dressed for the weather in
a windchill of negative 46 degrees
Celsius that's negative 451 degrees
Fahrenheit an 18 year old student was
found unresponsive a short walk from his
dorm on Wednesday and later died in the
hospital on Tuesday man froze to death
in a garage in Milwaukee Wisconsin
having apparently collapsed after
shovelling snow according to a medical
examiner that is so scary like what are
you what are you supposed to do like I
hope they cancelled school schools
cancelled people aren't going to work
but it seems like for some of these
people they weren't really going very
far right it was just that bad it's just
that bad I read about a man who like
maybe he was walking into his house and
he slipped and fell he was an old man
who couldn't get up and he know he's
just like freeze to death yeah well that
makes me so sad so sad so I hope all of
our Midwest Visser's and just
Midwesterners everywhere are saying form
and staying inside and staying safe and
I think it's at the tail end now right
like those yeah posterized yeah I think
it's gonna swing back that's so scary
but have you been seeing the picture
it's like it looks like a scene out of a
Dwayne the rock Johnson moon no yeah it
looks like it like like hell has frozen
over huh it's really crazy
Sam listen Chicago I should check on her
oh yeah she does you should yeah anyways
we'll keep you posted on the polar
vortex but it's just it's wild and I'm
sure you've seen those videos of people
like going outside with their wet hair
oh yeah they like me I was like hard as
a rock or something and someone took a
boiling pot of hot water outside and
threw it up and midair it turns into
snow that's crazy crazy that's how cold
it is like we think it's cooled here
like that's nothing right it actually is
really cold here it's like I
I mean I know it's definitely colder
don't get me wrong it was like I can
only imagine if this is if it's like
this here but it's like everywhere else
right I was leaving my building this
morning and someone walked in with a
suitcase and she was like with someone
and she was like oh my god it's so warm
here I guess she was coming from the
Northwest from the Midwest oh that's
crazy
wow that's really crazy okay next up
little crazier news go vegan and you
could win tickets to Beyonce and g
concert jay-z concerts for life I'm like
I think I'm just reading too much now I
have a reading comics yeah I didn't call
you out but when you were I think you
were trying to say Idaho you said I oh
really yeah I uh I uh when I was right
in slit [ __ ]
I did the podcast with Zack yesterday
and it's just podcast only and I was
reading so much and he was like kept
saying I was talking so much because I
was reading right and now it's like if
you want to read a story feel free
I actually do always volunteer to read
in class really because because it's an
easy way to get credit and I'm showing
and because everyone else weed so slowly
and I want to die and I read very fast
so it's over you know
yeah Beyonce and jay-z want to start a
vegan revolution in a post on the
irreplaceable singers insert on Thursday
she revealed that she's partnering with
green print project to give away 30
years of tickets to concerts featuring
herself in her rapper husband quote what
is your green print the mother of three
caption the photo which suggested
plant-based breakfasts and meatless
Monday's is two ways for newbies to try
out a more environmentally friendly diet
click the link in my bio for a chance to
win tickets to any Jay and/or my
shows for life to enter submit your name
and email the green project comm full
veganism isn't required you just have to
order and eat a few plant-based meals
the sweepstakes and an April 22nd
according to the official contest rules
so you got a few plans to win lifetime
tickets to Beyonce I think that there be
I'm sorry
this headline and all of the headlines
surrounding this is such fake news
because I thought it meant if you can
prove to be on say that you've been a
vegan for a month because she asked you
to be you win comes for tickets for like
no first of all this is a sponsorship
with green print you have to order just
a few meals and then your enter to win a
sweepstakes we're probably one or two
people wouldn't think of they are vegan
I feel like the biggest [ __ ] of all
time like that's what happens when you
like I don't read every story before I I
just want you to know that if I entered
an i won
I would give it to you its way because
that's how much I can't deal yeah with
jay-z and Beyonce I'm sure it's like if
it's like it's not even them directly I
I don't know why I'm so stupid why I
fell for this I thought it was like well
cuz you probably didn't read the whole I
didn't because I I I want to you know
enjoy the stories and not like know
what's good like I like to enjoy them
with the people right right Wow I'm the
biggest sucker of all time
I really thought like and I was like how
are they gonna prove to be Beyonce and
jay-z they could lie that they were
vegan for a month I was thinking that I
was like are you gonna have to like do a
food journal and take a picture every
time and be like hey this is what I ate
for the past month but no you just have
a food and I'm a student I'm sure the
food has to be from this company of
course and you don't even have to eat it
but you're getting charged I'm so
confused
wow I just reported on Beyonce and jay-z
sponsored post what a [ __ ]
wow wow wow Bethenny just wow do you see
the trailer for your Housewives of New
York I actually did it looks insane yeah
it does when does it come back maybe
I'll watch uh I think in a few months
but Beverly Hills comes back next week
and oh speaking of before what's so
crazy this is what's so crazy about the
world the first time I saw the trailer
for about early Hills it was months ago
and I was like this is never coming out
you know that feeling when it's like
they're seeing the trailer for greatest
showmen in July and it's coming on
December you're like I'm never
gonna see this right and that's what
I'll do i Beverly Hills like by the time
this comes out like I'm gonna be getting
married almost and now like it's coming
out next week I'm getting married almost
it's my wedding month it's crazy it's
like it's ever so it's really even
closer than you'd think
oh my god I'm freaking out and I'm
trying that's like panic cuz I'm out of
panic er I don't panic it I think I'm
not gonna you're not a panic ER cuz like
maybe I'll panic leading up to it but on
the day of I feel like you're gonna be
like cool is he cute I am but just
leading up to it it's a lot and it's we
invited a lot of people like this is a
very big event you know so I I feel like
wait I yeah it's just a lot of moving
parts you know I just wish I was like
getting married on the beach somewhere
with five of my closest counselors I
know that would've been so wet you know
now I'm like having remorse but it'll be
are you gonna drink your wedding of
course like are you gonna get like
[ __ ] up or like not oh I think I'm
gonna I'm not gonna get [ __ ] up till
the end I don't need to remember the end
right but I'm not gonna get [ __ ] up
until like after the main course yeah
you know cuz there's a lot to do before
then you know your first dance if people
make speeches I don't plan on making a
speech but I wanna you know something I
heard to make when we're correct I I
don't know I'll let you know
I might just it would be weird if like I
got married and my counselor didn't say
something right right right but we'll
see anyways now I'm freaking out so I
have to like go and deal with stuff you
know like somebody I should go on the
show and go plan my wedding
anyway so what I was saying that New
York is it feels so far off meanwhile to
be here before you know it what is it
supposed to be summer probably spring
that's how far the quarter and it looks
really so good the countess is like
being so countess he again and her in
Bethany or fighting which makes me sad
so Nia like falls off her chair and hits
her head on the floor really crazy stuff
oh I saw that one and Bethany was like
go to sleep or something and she was
like now then she fell yeah yeah scary
and there's a new housewife which is
just like going into the Lions Den okay
I gotta get on there I actually started
watching Real Housewives of New York
from the beginning with Claudia and then
I just like taking when you know you
have so far to go I just like but you
love that I don't know it's different
it's different like watching a reality
show because it's like I know this this
isn't like happening
yeah versus when I just like watch
seasons because it's like I don't know
nor will anybody really tell me because
it's fake yeah you know I do now okay
next up Gwyneth Paltrow slams lawsuit
over alleged hit-and-run ski accident
Gwyneth Paltrow's being sued for
allegedly pulling a hit-and-run while
skiing the alleged incident took place
on the slopes of the Deer Valley Resort
in Park City Utah in February 2016 court
documents obtained by E News alleged
Gwyneth Paltrow's skied out of control
and hit the back of Terry Sanderson 72
another skier who was downhill when the
award-winning actress hit the doctor the
complaint alleges she knocked him down
hard knocking him out and causing a
brain surgery for broken ribs and other
injuries / the skier responsibility code
which is a summit county ordinance
skiers are required to require to
immediately stop at the scene of such
collision and render to any person
injured in such collision responsible
assistance the ordinance also requires
that any skiers involved in a collision
shall give his name and address to an
employee of the ski area operator
however Sanderson and other witnesses
claim Paltrow got up turned and skied
away leaving Sanderson stunned lying in
the snow seriously injured Sanderson
also alleges that the instructor falsely
accused Sanderson of causing the crash I
don't know I have some thoughts on this
because as you know skier myself not
gonna lie there sometimes but for me
it's like I'm not good enough that I can
stop myself it's more so that when I'm
like speeding and I'm trying to like
slow down and like on my last ski trip I
like fully banged into somebody but
that's because the person brought me
also didn't know how to ski so like she
was just like really just like going
like right in front of me and I kept
saying watch out watch out I kept
dodging her but if you keep going in
front of me you know at some point
you're going down with me so I did stop
see if she was okay but the thing that
skiing is like sometimes you just can't
stop so it's like if she hit him and
then but she was with an instructor and
she seems like she would be a good skier
it seems weird that the instructor would
do that like the instructor worked for
the resort like handle it as you should
you know yeah I don't know but it's like
can you even sue someone over that over
a ski and run because like Joe how many
people probably ski and run like on the
daily yeah it's like skiing is like a
one-man sport it is on
to just stay like oh my got it alive but
imagine if your senior staying alive and
someone else takes you down yeah oh my
god I would kill someone if someone did
next second finally I got my [ __ ]
together guys
yeah see I'm really dangerous old I
think about that all the time by the way
the fact that there's not more skiing
accidents is truly like so shocking
because it is honestly so scary like so
I see it like so unsafe you know no but
there are a lot of scene accidents
that's how the mom from Parent Trap guy
I know I think about that all the time
now and she was definitely like a
seasoned woman she was like skiing in
the Alps right and she definitely
probably run out people didn't wear a
helmet no you think people he ever
Martha no they don't I noticed a lot of
people don't wear helmets really yes I
think they're like so good and cool I
don't think Kim wears a helmet
really I'm she's good and cool right
exactly but it all takes is like one
fall
I could watch videos of Kim skiing for
hours on end I can watch videos of
people that are like good and not like
Olympic champions skiing like on Lou Lou
but like the way that Kim Kardashian's
skis it's like so like sultry yes I
watched a video of her skiing while we
were on a ski trip right it [ __ ] me up
for the rest of the time cuz I just
wanted to let her know what I was
singing like that's where the goal is is
to move your hips like that and I was I
wasn't at that level I forgot like how
to ski at an intermediate level I
understand because I would saw that and
like do you think she likes skis like
that like on blacks i I think so those
those mountains I don't think those were
greens no way she does greens they're
all such goods using you we just never
guess it no but it like makes total
sense cuz like they definitely went as
like children and then like you know
they've been going forever and I don't
know like that's that's a goal of mine
would be to like just be like so epic at
skiing that it's like we're on our way
we're do it for people who grew up and
never sleep people who I went into last
year uh-huh like I'm not that bad yeah
except like I get a little out of
control because you know I'm Speedy
Gonzales and it's something I'm trying
to work on right no but like I think
it's pretty impressive that we found
ourselves to ski at our adult age me too
except we know how to ski and taught
herself to ski but we can teach
ourselves to drive right but there's a
big difference between getting behind
the what do you think is more dangerous
behind the wheel I learned to drive or
skiing honestly it's a debate it is I'm
sure I'm sure there are numbers that
will tell us what's more dangerous
numbers okay next up a story that I've
been following cuz I just think it's
hilarious and and hilarious and sweet
ariana grande updates her Japanese
tattoo and still can't get it right palm
readers are still pointing the finger at
Ariana Grande's new and allegedly
improved hand tattoo grande said
Thursday she fixed the misspelled
Japanese hand tied after fans lambasted
it on social media
the thank you next pop star posted a new
photo of the tattoo her instagram story
thursday with the caption quote slightly
better thanks to my tutor for helping me
fix and to the tattoo artist at cane
Navis ardh her being a legend and to my
doctor for the lidocaine shots no joke
grande initially revealed her new palm
tattoo britain kanji characters Tuesday
night and intended to read seven rings
but as we all know now it translated to
a small bar Braille she wrote r.i.p tiny
charcoal grill grande equipped in the
caption of the photo of her new hand
tattoo miss you man I actually really
liked him but social media users pointed
out that Grande's new tat was still
misspelled why how now Ariana's tattoo
reads Japanese barbecue finger I know
I'm gonna need it if she's learning
Japanese she should fire her tutor for
anyone who wonders it now says she has
barbecue fingers that is so confused so
funny
I don't know how she keeps getting your
money there but I guess I wonder if what
she said it's true that it's like it's
not a permanent place at it like peels
off cuz I guess skins always growing on
your hands yes when you get it hard but
if it's like okay if she just left small
charcoal grill that would have been
pretty funny and at this one it's like
an inside joke that the world we're all
in on and we're enjoying but no they do
his eyes and now but she went to fix it
so like you know she didn't want it to
be a funny joke and she [ __ ] up again
she does need to fire her tutor yeah I
honestly also shouldn't the tattoo
artist know what he's writing to know
it's not you bring the tattoo artist it
was out of every language in the world
okay all right I just didn't know I've
never gotten one no you haven't but what
would you get Connie and I played this
um honestly I would just like either
like I
something like on my hand okay well like
tiny what would you guys like maybe
either like a Jewish star something
written in Hebrew rocks teeny vibes
maybe that it's about like just like you
know one of those like cool little
things yeah I couldn't I knew I wanted
rock scene you guys but I didn't know
where I would put it but I would put it
on my finger just like my favorite
counsel what did you say that last time
um I think maybe I wound up with here
that's such a classic like Miley like
what was I just believe yeah oh my god
yes that's a classic Miley yeah she's
doing so well she's doing so well like I
did her I just like I'm so proud of her
she I mean she really came full circle I
know they're so cute I was watching
Hunger Games this weekend and I'm so
happy he's in that movie with rebel
Wilson I know well here's the thing
about the movie like it looks exactly
like a movie I want to see this new
rebel Wilson romantic comedy that's not
a romantic comedy but it's about
memories horrible I don't think it looks
horrible I like I can tell it's gonna be
a terrible movie but like I have to see
it do you
yeah I'm gonna see it for sure for sure
okay so fifth and final story is a
two-parter some TV news actually I'm
gonna make it a four partner because Wow
Wow first bit of news Riverdale's
renewed for season four oh yes that
doesn't come as a shock to me whatsoever
second bit of news dynasties are an
infra season that comes to me as a shock
just because I feel like nobody's
listening to me what I say it's the best
show on television I know how their
numbers are you guys it's the best show
we'll recap it at the end so that people
who don't watch can go and start
watching but I don't know how many more
times we have to say it like you have to
watch the show you just have to watch
the show it is so good
so ascetically pleasing the clothes ate
the clothing the plot the character is
like a plus the writing the writing the
Fallon it's so good okay
fourth part to the story Gossip Girl
reboot discussion is underway at the CW
CW president Mark Pedowitz told
reporters at the CW's portion of the TV
Critics Association press tour on
Thursday that there's a discussion
happening when it comes to a reboot of
Gossip Girl but I don't know if we're
there yet
Pedowitz said I don't know what it would
be but it all comes down to the
involvement of the original EPS Josh
Schwartz and Stephanie Savage
because you don't want to do anything
without them you
Gossip Girl undid in 2012 and as of 2016
SAE X TV festival Schwartz and savage
were saying they hadn't thought about
rebooting the show at all we haven't
really explored some of those
conversations towards to--they news back
then maybe I don't know we haven't
really thought about it okay what do you
think about it here's the thing the
thing is is that I just can't imagine
that like Blake Lively and like Leighton
Meester like just like come back and
like just pick up where they left off I
just feel like they're both over it
right and like leave me sirs on a sitcom
now playing a mom right and it's just
like yeah lately sirs career didn't
really like take off per se after Gossip
Girl but I still think that she's like
just done being Blair Waldorf
I'm sure Podesta's is ower would jump at
the opportunity but like I feel like
what they might do is like a spin-off
type of Gossip Girl with a new cast
which is like whatever but I don't know
I just like feel like it's not actually
gonna happen like I just can't see it
actually happening yeah um I don't want
it to happen yeah I don't want it to
happen at all first of all there hasn't
been enough time in between the I
understand that everyone is all about
reboot season now because like we have
no new original ideas so let's go back
to some of the old successful ones but
it hasn't even been like 10 years so it
would be like admitting that we should
have never ended the show to begin with
right and so they wouldn't pick up where
they left off because yeah Serena and
Blair are now like 35 years later isn't
that how long it's been and I don't
think they could get the whole cast back
and we just be it would be a sad version
of a perfect show I couldn't agree more
but what I do think it's time for a
reboot reboot for is actually I don't
know how long it's been either oh I'm
totally wrong but Desperate Housewives
oh I just need it but I actually think
it and a decently but they could bring
back Desperate Housewives in an easy way
like all they need is one or two of the
women to come back and live on the block
no they just need a teri hatcher to like
have died have died yeah and then like
all the ladies come back together and
they're like so sad and then that way
Susan's about on the show anymore I
think it's a brilliant plan you can also
bring in new houses people move on to a
new street all the time and also people
leave the street so if someone didn't
want to come back it wouldn't be a big
deal I know oh so I know that I've
watched all of OC and Zack had a really
good ideas that they should bring back
OC
and from the perspective of Kirsten and
Sandy's daughter that they had in the
last season forgot about her was her
name I forget but she was cute and it
could be like so maybe now she's like a
freshman in high school right and they
could start the OSI all over again maybe
they bring in a girl now like just like
Adam I'm sorry Seth and Ryan now we have
daughter and daughter daughter and
daughter daughter and daughter they
could be like sisters
or like camper and counselor they could
so I would be more here for that and
then I will say about Gossip Girl they
wanted to do a spinoff
luckily the books already have been
written it's called it girl and it's a
Jenny Humphrey goes to boarding school
[ __ ] away why those books were good no
but I'm just mad I hate Jenny Humphrey
no but just say what if it wasn't played
by Taylor mom sinks obviously she would
she got rented yeah okay so it's just a
spin-off or you know what they oh
nevermind I think I read a girl or like
the a-list those books oh my god you're
missing out I should read them you're
missing out I just finished a book last
night so it's so good I'm looking for
something new I don't even know what's
better honestly between goes well
between a list and a girl are they think
is it girl Gossip Girl or no no eight
girl is Gossip Girl spin-off Jenny
Humphrey go supporting school right
right and it's all about her life at
boarding school okay
and she liked it better and when you go
eating those I was too young so I was
reading like the click books with
massive lock right I mean we were all
reading the click books even though we
were in college and they were in seventh
grade yeah but I was like in fifth so I
was a lot older girls yeah anyways I
would I would go for an eight girl
spin-off what I would not go for and
what they tried to do remember at the
time was they were trying to like do
flashbacks to like Lily and her sister
Lily van der Woodsen memories in the 80s
they were trying to do a spin-off show
like the Carrie Diaries a prequel show
please no got into that except I will
say Carrie Diaries was the best show
ever and it got cancelled and it was
just really like so sad was it the best
show after show watch it now oh my god
you should watch it you would really
like it it's not like Carrie Bradshaw be
annoying you forget that she's supposed
to be like Sarah Jessica Parker 100 days
just like knowing what
mr. later in life you forget you really
forget you should really watch and I
really think you'd like it it is such a
good show and Austin Butler is the love
interest and I love him okay I think
about it think about it I think I think
you'd enjoy it okay you know cancer
might be able to convince me anyways if
any one of the CW ones who approached us
about any of the ideas that we stood on
this show let us know we're available
Stephanie Savage and I agree don't you
touch anything unless the original
people are involved yeah which just
makes me I don't which just makes me sad
again about the Royals cancellation Oh
why'd you have to bring that I don't
know oh my god that was so like also
they left it on the cliffhanger so the
last thing like they at least oh it's
just one episode explaining what
happened like are you kidding me oh my
god I forgot and I just have so many
that was seriously the best show no I
know and it like just like skated under
the radar I'm like our Eleanor and Jess
were dating in real life she always
instagrams with him but it's like I
think they might either be like really
close friends or they're dating the
comment everyone's unclear and it's like
I just got to know I love I love the
Wardrobe honestly like rival talents
well I was gonna say that like I can't
believe they canceled that show I want
to like rewatch it even though I just
watched it even though the whole time
you know your you have depression
looming because it's canceled and you
never get answers and I haven chose to
that it is so unfair it's even if they
can make like a five minute like
webisode or just text me like tell me
what happened
okay next story part two and TV news
fuller house is ending with season five
prepare to say goodbye to the Tanner
family again when solar house ends with
the upcoming fifth and final season on
Netflix Netflix released an emotional
farewell video featuring clips from the
previous four seasons in the cast of the
full house sequel series saying goodbye
we're saving the best for last Candace
Cameron Bure says in the video above
Cameron Bure returned to her full house
character DJ Tanner and now DJ Tanner
fuller oh that's cute I didn't I don't
watch Oh me neither i watch the first
the first season she married someone
named fuller now it's fuller house
because it's awesome full more full
house I thought she was single for the
sequel series that followed her
character raising her family with the
help of her sister Stephanie and her
best friend Kimmy Gibbler original cast
members Bob Saget Lori Loughlin and Dave
Coulier all made by girl
our appearances as did John Stamos who
also served as an executive producer
okay so this is coming to a close and I
just I couldn't be more pleased about it
because it never should have been
rebooted to begin with why can't we let
sleeping dogs lie I agree and I also saw
in the toasters which I don't this could
be completely unconverted think they're
releasing this statement to see how
people react and like I could get picked
back up do you know but yeah now that I
can go inside
watch it but we like who needs this no I
don't know anyone who was like a full
house scan back in the day you're not
gonna watch a show like that because now
they're probably watching things like
dynasty days now they're busy no but now
they're they're not trying to watch a
little like sitcom or whatever about
like kids now they've grown up and
they're watching you know like real
shows right like you you used to stand
full house back in the day am i the age
of people watch well now you're a little
younger but um you I think probably I'm
the age and and I'm here not I'm not
interested but you're a little younger I
used to love full house I remember like
you and Claudia in the den like just
being obsessed with full house really
but you guys are so weird
but I'm saying no you didn't even watch
all her house I remember Zack was so
excited for it to come back and I'm
pretty one was everything's like jazzed
about it
right and then season one came out and
it was like it was fine I watched the
whole thing I remember and then I was
like I'm not watching like the rest of
it I'm not going through with this right
I remember the trailer that came out for
season one when they played that song
haha Miranda Lambert song um what it's
called like about home which I hate her
so no no it's a good song hold on are
you looking up now yeah because it's a
good song and it was it was so good
Miranda Lambert the house that built me
oh that is a good song I'll give it to
her man the trailer for season one a
fuller house they were like walking
through the house and it was empty and
they were playing that song okay well
you see it here's the thing that pulls
people's heart string heartstrings
because of a nostalgia and then that was
the last good idea that they had yes
precisely and and also it was dead in
the water when they didn't get Mary Kate
and Ashley back oh of course
which is like honestly that like
mary-kate and Ashley are just so smart
do you know what I mean
I'm yes yeah like they just knew like
come on guys but even if it was a really
dead horse even if it was a huge success
they we're never gonna be back on it
like they're so busy right now and so
prestigious and like been so edgy yeah
it's a like there were such cute little
babies and like now there are these
women who just like we're like all black
like cuffed all fuller house would not
know what to do with them say they even
came to set and we're like okay you know
what well dress us like what you want no
they would have to make them like oh you
know Michelle right that was her name
the baby Michele Adelman name it was a
long time ago no it's not it's a normal
name wish Michelle like moved to the big
city and became a fashion designer and
now is like she is like killing it they
would have to just let every for their
articles I agree I agree they but we're
what Lisbeth and James yeah the row is
that them yeah the row and Elizabeth and
James yeah yeah but the row is like more
national yeah and it's so expensive it's
a it's weird how expensive it is
considering what it is I actually looked
up their net worth a little bit ago like
there they made so much money
like from being fashion designer it's
not just like from then also so people
say there's like no money in fashion you
know like it's so hard for it to get
from season to season you know reap the
retail industry is very difficult if you
watch Shark Tank
so speaking of shark tank speaking of
shark tank oh my god I can't believe we
didn't I just wasn't talking about this
nice a Mark Cuban shark and so I was
invited to the knick game and I was like
Oh Dallas Mavericks like I love like
Dallas you know country music that's
that's my you know head and then I I
knew that Mark Cuban on the Dallas
Mavericks but I forgot I guess it just
slipped my mind and I didn't know that
he'd be there whatever then I sit down
on my seat they were great seats I'm
just right in front of me it's Mark
Cuban and I actually think I lost my
[ __ ] I like I just like was freaking out
and I don't think I watched the game for
two seconds like I was just watching him
and like in between like when it was
like they'd called timeout he just go
and stand on the court just like chill
and I was like you're so epic and then
like the whole time I was like I have to
have a very mature he was right there
like how could I not and the waiter like
saw me freaking out who's like just do
it like just ask and I was like okay it
was
time and there's 30 seconds left before
the players started coming out and that
was like what was it between us you know
like little thing when people come out
and I was like mark don't worry what can
I take a selfie I did I came over and
then it started a whole slew of ever and
I was asking for pictures to make me
feel like a [ __ ] but always how's the
first one so I'd have to be like think
it would do yeah and then I was like
you're my favorite shark and he was like
thank you and he just likes he was
definitely very nice but he was like let
me get this over with right right which
is like I respect that you are a very
busy man you have like things to do like
you own a basketball team in there
playing I get it yeah you were very
understanding and I just like my whole
focus when taking a picture I was like
don't do the celebrity smiles right for
if you guys don't know her go and she
meet celebrities she takes a picture
with them like she oh wait she can't
help herself she looks like the nerdiest
most excited person in the world she
gets the biggest man but I don't even
feel myself doing it but it can't be
stopped even one time when we were
meeting I think was like Olivia culpo
and I was like just don't do the
celebrity kill smile no teeth and like
she says a smile like with no teeth but
she's like it's bursting bursting so you
didn't do your celebrity smile you stuck
your tongue out yes which was like cute
no it was like fine but it's like
inappropriate it's like he's like so
like you know serious and business and
it's like you know you did it cutely and
you didn't have any would you rather
that or celebrity smile that you
couldn't have posted that because I
wouldn't been able to post a celebrity
smile without like somehow making my
face half the size no it's so hard to
take a picture when you meet the
celebrity cuz it's like you don't want
to do a half smile because you know
whatever comes out the way you want
because you're so excited like you need
to be like very like and you don't want
to seem like you're not excite
not excited but your person for a
picture right so you smile and then you
look like a huge dweeb
yes that's me I'm dweeby vibes yeah but
you weren't you played a cop later cool
with the shark yes and it's a shark
I met Mark Cuban you should I'd pitch
him about the toes then I was like oh he
would've been like oh this [ __ ] trying
to get money no and then he would have
if he ever heard about the toes ever
again he would have like unfavorable
feeling right so I didn't even though
I'll be although I would never have the
balls to do it right and why would you
upset I don't know something that went
over to the bathroom
I don't know what I mean
oh my god snitch on the tank snitch on
the tank snitch on the take snitch on
the tank we haven't even seen snitch on
toast once I feel like we're past that
you know right because now your
counselor Disney chess right the best
counselor in the world and the best
sister in the world except I still don't
know if you're my sister because you
haven't sent in your 23andme kit I
haven't I've been meaning to it's just
lying around I'm kind of scared like
what if it comes back and it's like
switch at birth right or like except I
just like have so many high numbers to
compete with now Claudia posted a video
last night that was in the toasters
where she took a shot and then in her
face she looks exactly like you of
course cuz I'm always making that face
but did you see it I did and I commented
so I sometimes me and her do you really
have the same face but that's probably
because you know we're related yes so
even if you do 23andme it'll probably
tell you what you already know but you
know it would be nice to get some
confirmation also did you know that was
23andme you can get a bunch of reports
that will tell you more about yourself
I'm what your Jenica genetically
predisposed to like a deep sleep report
if you've always suspected that you feel
more sleepy than others after missing
out on a night of sleep you might not be
imagining things your genes may be
involved oh my god I need to do this
room I definitely have that I'm the most
tired person on the planet me too
and it's like all I do is sleep you can
do an alcohol flush reaction report oh
man quarts sweet vs. salty taste report
as saturated fat and weight report the
saturated fat and weight report can tell
you about how about how your genetics
may impact your body's response to your
diet learn if you are likely to weigh
more on a diet and high saturated fat
even if you consume the same number of
calories I mean this is so interest on
teh make sure it now when you send it in
do these reports - good thing you eat it
that's true and you guys at 23andme
health and ancestry kit is the perfect
gift for Valentine's Day buy your kid
today at 23andme dot-com slash toast
that's the number two three and me.com
slash toast
again that's 23andme comm slash toast
honestly now we're gonna go home and you
know swab I need to do that how longs it
take to come back from it it says it
takes I think two weeks for me was
shorter so I think they overestimate it
not it's not very long and it's there
before you know it and you got it in
your email oh you get in your email oh
that's so nice like I'm not trying to
open some mail right now yeah you
definitely are not a person who uses
mail no I'm not
anyways that is all the news you needed
to know this morning now I'm here let's
recap dynasty and revered ale but I'm
two episodes behind so I'm up to the
episode where Archie went into the woods
and he's in the cabin and then it ends
with his like dreams and stuff but like
when I said what I said to you when we
were I know he's not dead yeah because I
was talking about your like you've
ruined it oh my god I was just giving
you [ __ ] counselor oh I thought you
actually owe you [ __ ] I never know with
you you know that's sheriff especially
over text but cuz also right arrest
posted the cast list for Heather's
musical episode and every minute Archie
and also like you think that I'm Archie
Andrews like you can't kill Archie
Andrews like it's based off of the
Archie comics right no I don't mean like
like actually like oh my God he's Archie
- I kind of feel like he's champion a
champion thing at this season and bear
with me usually he's annoying he makes
bad decisions but now he's just being
like a badass and like he just doesn't
care and like honestly I'm here for him
breaking up with Veronica I think that
was a smart move for him because like he
is just like mentally unstable like he
couldn't handle it and like I get that I
love Veronica and I love Archie but I
know they how you feel veggie I'm here
for it just cuz they by the way I just
want I just want you to know that like
two times ago when I when I was on the
show I said this I was like I feel like
they're gonna incorporate them dating in
the show because they're dating in real
life yeah
right or ass is very in tune to that
right but it's like I kind of don't like
that because like I want you to tell me
what happens I don't want to tell you
what should happen do you know what I
mean
yeah I just I always knew that as of
Archie shipper that they were gonna have
to go through it and probably breakup
because all of these elements that are
working against them no one could
withstand no I think they need to
complete sense for them to break up I
mean they need to break out or dad
literally literally is trying to kill
him right they need to break up Veronica
and Charles Melton veggie veggies like
they can explore I think that barchi
will come back together and once
everyone's stronger and the Dustin I
just really make sense that it would be
like bug-head endgame
marches and game cuz that's just
probably like how it should be yeah you
know you have to some character
development things have to you have to
change some things around sometimes you
do and as long as you don't change bug
head I feel like that's like a steady
ship I mean I don't want them to change
bug head because both of them are so
annoying I don't want them to annoy
other people really I can't do anything
like Betty on the show she is the whole
show she's okay but she's just like
always being stupid I can't explain
she's never been she's like like making
the right decisions and being smart and
just trying to do what's right
yeah I'd completely disagree she's like
someone who keeps going out into the
woods alone and like wondering why she
ended up at the sisters you know okay
that's very interesting the wrong people
on like so far the farm I know I'm sure
they're at their bad about Alice is
bugging the hell out of me like she's
the way she's never been better
no she's she's ready I attended woman Oh
hardly
actually and you know um two episodes
Minds I don't know if there's been farm
developments oh I forgot no this has
really been farm developments but she
still just be and I know that she's got
Heather's the musical episode it said
presented by the farm up top okay yeah
so why would Betty clap and I'm so
excited for that musical so because some
of us had to suffer through carry the
musical and really know if we didn't
watch them and I like that they don't
that they choose like ones like that not
like High School Musical because like
what Archie's gonna play Troy Bolton
actually I'd been here for that actually
I would be here for that do you want to
go off about rent live oh I would love
to and like people were yelling at me
like I know that there are some people
probably feels passionate about like
Broadway as I do about like you know
Taylor Swift so it's like if someone
came for Taylor Smith even if she did
something bad like I would demand that
give Taylor so it see the halftime show
and it was unequivocally terrible and I
and people were saying things maybe
nobody talked about it was great I get
that it's called blind loyalty I got it
but rent live like I don't even know how
one could even like try to say that it
was good like the fact of Anessa Hudgens
was probably the best part of the show
it's just mind-boggling
do you already mean actually you know
who's actually really good book was like
Jordan Fisher you thought he was good I
thought he was like a bad actor but it
felt like his heart was in it then he
had one thing I'll say he was trying no
one else was really trying to give any
to dress rehearsal but then why you
could air it
I'm not gonna you have to show me
something I should have to stand up for
it everyone keeps saying but it was a
dress rehearsal like they didn't know
like it's our fault that it was a dress
rehearsal
it doesn't matter if you're a dress [ __ ]
if you're a dress rehearsal wasn't you
know what the thing that you want us to
see them what you wanted to put out
there [ __ ] postpone the show the
advertisers can wait or do it live in a
wheelchair or you so many things that
were said that they could have done
Roger scenes from the rehearsal and let
everyone else do it live okay hey
everyone there is so like well-versed in
Broadway right have you ever heard of an
understudy right that's first second
postpone the show nobody would have
cared truly I don't really think anybody
was like counting down the days everyone
was like oh right live is tonight great
I'll watch it you know yeah and I could
have done that in two months from now
yeah I just think that whoever made that
decision it was the worst possible
decision that they could have made it
was so terrible I just couldn't get over
it no I was like I feel like I was like
I feel like this isn't real like this is
a joke and then he was also on when the
SAG Awards were on and I was like I
never watched a SAG Awards I didn't even
know that they were televised do you
know what I mean yeah it's like all
these awards
here's another but it's like it's a
award show CBS are basically the same
shows right all the same movies are
nominated same categories and it's like
why am i watching the same thing 100
times I don't like what it I am I going
to matching it the first time I
understand the point of an Oscar bit all
the rest are basically the same type of
thing Golden Globes SAG Awards why do I
have to watch it 100 times I mean for
the fascial that's like number I would
say that somewhere like 57 of my
questions that I have for Hollywood
right but it's also like can you just
throw in some musical performances like
spice it up a bit or the see that the
Oscars are like not having all the Best
Original Song nominees sing yeah they
always do yeah so I saw somewhere that
they're not and lin-manuel Miranda saw
it and like tweeted something and cuz
like I guess Mary Poppins song got the
boot which I can't say and put happy
about it and he was like if this is
really true like he went off you know
but apparently the only two that are
gonna be sung are shallow obviously and
a kendrick lamar one that's i'm
confirmed but um i read it and
lin-manuel responded to it so there has
to be some weight to it interest on
but that's what I I need I need musical
performances to get me through joining
mean I can't deal with this talking and
the stupid jokes that aren't funny I
find a word shows like in the fact of
those three hours yeah the SAG words
were so short when it was over I was
like oh my god it's over I know I know
I've never had lately before thank you
Mario was good in rent life he played
the guy who who was looking for the rent
who they owed the rent to I can remember
I shot I shot it off in the middle okay
nobody was saying that when I thought
the same thing and Zach and I meant to
mention it last time but I forgot and
then I was also reading an article about
like justice for all these villains like
Gaston and Sharpay and one of it was
like justice for what's-his-name in the
I forget what his name is in the movie
but the rent the guy who needs rent
looks like he's just trying to get paid
you know write your [ __ ] rent but he
said that they never had to pay but it's
like this is New York City or living on
the Lower East Side you're gonna get it
right there's no such thing as a free
rent I wish and all they but I don't
want to go into the pot like anyways
dynasty oh yeah I went I was something
else to save it and now it's just
slipping my mind um people wanted me to
recap Real Housewives of New Jersey
which I have to do because it was insane
it was one of the craziest episodes to
the Housewives that we've had in a very
long time okay um there was just they
couldn't stop fighting and then it was
like a fire would be put out in another
it was like whack-a-mole of fights you
know like at the dinner table and I
thought that the fight between Margaret
at first of all in my thesis on this
week's episode is team Margaret all of
the way every which way
Michio Kushi follows me the fight
between and as a person I love her and
on the show I'm totally with her and if
I between her and Jennifer like just
kept getting escalated and escalated and
it didn't need to and I'm so glad that
they squashed it immediately and like I
know I felt good about it
ending Margaret did Jennifer did
everyone was like fine with it because
what happened was they bought this
necklace for Teresa because she finished
her competition and competition name is
like a diamond necklace it said strong
they get so nice yeah it was like
Margaret's idea and Melissa and they
went and bought it and they made it it's
real diamonds and they give it to they
go on vacation to celebrate the Teresa's
done with her competition and they give
her the necklace and Jennifer who has
been drinking and she's also like you
know beefs with Margaret a little bit
she
like she didn't realize they were buying
a real diamond necklace they thought she
thought it was asking but she was just
going in on the gift she was like wait
you bought a real diamond necklace
finding you go to my brother he's a
jeweler in front of Teresa as she's
getting him it's just really like it was
bad for him but she had been drinking
and then it just got crazy because
everything that Jennifer was saying was
pissing Margaret off and Margaret was
like uh Margot was like you're drunk lay
public and Jennifer's like no I'm on
point she's like really you're on point
your lip liner looks like a monkey's ass
hole Jennifer goes a monkey's ass hole
thank you [ __ ] sucked
it was crazy that's crazy because you
know when your lipstick like when when
you're eating and drinking and talking
the inside goes away just the liner yeah
but she won and her lips her liner was
like a dark brown and her lips were a
lighter brown oh my and you know it
didn't not look like a monkey's ass it
was so fun that is funny and so then the
next day they like kind of move on from
it and then at dinner that night they
get into it again and Jennifer is
talking about Margaret's mom I guess she
like had an affair with a married man
for a long time and Margaret met her
husband they weren't married to other
people at the time and Margaret's just
going in on talking about who Jennifer's
going and talking about who Margaret's
mom sleeps with like all this really
below the belt oh and Margaret goes she
was like will your husband sleeps in the
pool house and and she was like no he
does and she was like you're right he's
sleeping at his girlfriend's house she
was being so mean she was like that's
word on the street and then Jennifer got
it from the table she was so upset
obviously she'll be asleep out and
Margaret I mean immediately I'm in and
she was like I don't know that I just
said that to get under her skin and just
make her mad so Jennifer comes back to
the table and Margaret like she had a
pit and she was like I'm sorry I said
that I was below the belt
I just was like really just trying well
good for her because I feel like no one
ever apologized no one ever apologizes
so Jennifer accepted her apology and
they really moved on the next day
they're having a nice time they're on
camels riding good time then they go to
dinner and Danielle and Theresa start
bringing up what Margaret said the night
before even though everyone else had
moved on was what that a bad first
assessment
okay and then Danielle just starts going
and on Margaret talking about how her
kids don't talk to her grandchildren
don't talk to her wiring her kids around
her and Margaret is like Margaret's I
can tell you were irrelevant to me and
not even listen to her but King L won't
stop when eventually Margaret
there's a drink hunting Ellen walks out
and then Danielle is still talking about
how Margaret is so wrong and Teresa is
taking gang outside and like it's
impossible are Teresa and Margaret
nearly there usually fine but ever since
Danielle and Margaret have had beef
Teresa has taken Danielle side and
Danielle is completely wrong completely
and then so Melissa jumps in and it's
like Teresa how are you taking ding
outside right now like it is so clear
like it was just so clear and I felt so
bad for Margo like she stormed off like
people are talking about her family and
it's like in New Jersey there is like
they have an unwritten role you know
they're very like blood is thicker than
water
right you do not talk about people's
families you don't talk about their
husbands you don't talk about their kids
and you don't talk about their moms
everyone's talking out margaret's
husbands kids mom and it's okay right
and the Chi thirsty drinking cheese were
wrong right
it was so so crazy and it just made me
like so upset that then Teresa like is
even saying in her interview so not even
in the heat of the moment that
Margaret's wrong she's still standing
back she's still defending Danielle and
it's like how right how it was so crazy
and then Jennifer is like still like
turning up and drinking so much when
she's drinking she's being so crazy and
someone's like someone threw a wine
glass and everyone was like it wasn't me
it wasn't me and Melissa was like no
Jennifer was you and Jennifer grabs a
glass smacks down on table she's like if
it was me you know it was it was so it
was really one of the wildest episodes
of house I've said I've seen in so long
wow that is crazy
you should watch I know it's just so
much work and it's like where do I start
actually really want to watch me but you
are always looking for shows to watch I
know but there's something about I just
like hate like catching up on like
reality shows do you know I mean because
it's like I know that this isn't
relevant anymore when I'm so far right
but here's but you should watch the
Vanderpump rules by now the stuff that
happened in season one that like has
nothing to do with where we're at today
it's we're almost like watching
different people we're like right
Stassi and Jax are dating I actually I
regret I think I might've watched the
first end when you guys were watching
Jax got someone in Vegas pregnant and no
one believes it but like Stassi was like
I think that it's true and all of her
friends like left her they all took Jax
aside and it turned out to be true does
he have a kid now no no no I don't know
what happened I don't know if they like
got an abortion or it whatever it was
crazy
oh wow that's crazy so you you need to
get a little more into the Bravo
universe
but I understand that like when I was in
college I wasn't watching Real
Housewives I miss a lot of seasons but
now that you're gonna be an adult sooner
I think that it's time Oh God
just another pit to add yeah you have a
lot going on too adult world what are
you feeling about The Bachelor this is
this season um like you know torture I
know who wins because some [ __ ]
ruined it for me so it's like it's like
it's like you watch with a different
perspective you know but I don't know
like I know you love Colton I don't not
like Colton it's just like I feel like
the show is just a fake show like I'm
watching a show that is just a scripted
TV series by ABC I don't know I just
think I feel the need to protect a
Colton I understand no I'm not going in
on him it's more so a thing of just like
the production and all that it's like
all these girls are thirsty monster
generals not one of them is there to
actually find love even probably the
person who wins like it just is so fake
I don't know I've had a real I've had my
Chinese who doesn't actually like give
up his virginity for this show do you
know what I mean yeah oh that would be
so so sad yeah like you but there's been
so many steamy makeouts like oh I can't
have a Gillian and him on the bed it's
gotta get so steamy in the fantasy so
well cuz I'm sure he's like you know
ready jumping on it but it's I don't
know I have no idea I really really
would love Hanna G to be the
Bachelorette but like they'll never give
us what we want ever no I and I don't
know if I want her to be that right and
I don't I haven't heard enough from I
don't want her on purpose she's like
what's her story does she have a story I
don't know remember well in last week's
episode when she was like I really want
to open up she didn't say one thing no
then she acted she was like I feel so
much better if that was her opening up
that she's nervous like she won't be a
Bachelorette right because she would
just not have a story she might have
just lived an easy life right we just
want but like we need a back shot that's
a little more dynamic yeah I don't know
but I feel like the minute are you
feeling some sort of resentment towards
like this season and Colton because
you're not there fighting for it is no I
think about that actually by the way all
the time like imagine you wouldn't have
crush that fitness competition I know I
was thinking that I could totally move
that limo um I don't know I just I just
don't think I could like handle it like
I think that if I didn't does this
season like
like you could have made some good
friends and I feel like I could have
made some good friends I feel like you
and Tammy with his it off I really like
her
no I like her too I think Kourtney is a
psychopath yeah truly through and
through and like the fact that he sent
her home was like honestly Bravo he's
doing everything right and he sent home
Tracy so we don't have to be subject to
any of her poor fashion choices
no and Demi was like and Demi just like
was winning she's like bye-bye she was
fighting she was like who else Melanie
dynasty that's really what I'm here to
talk about that's really why I showed up
this morning go off sis okay once again
truly the greatest show on television
Liz Gillies just is unparalleled with my
hair it's like I just I love her so much
and the stories and the characters are
so great but now let me get specific if
you haven't watched the last week's
episode I'm sorry
Liam's back and Fallon is fighting
fighting to win and I just have to say I
think last week's episode was one of the
most iconic best episodes that they've
had because there are so many scenes
that were just like amazing and they
went to get your group meeting when they
went skiing and you know we love skiing
as we spoken about so like the skiing
fast Sean I was here for and then there
was just so many things like oh the
scene where Kirby who by the way I
really love Kirby and I knew I would
you always I always said I was always
rooting for her like in the beginning
she's supposed to be crazy psycho like I
knew that wasn't actually what it was
Ella forms right fella fortin's Bowie
boys together so Sam and her doing like
the whole you know thing on the person's
on whatever amber was on her name that
was just like epic like you know like
girl power and then obviously like the
bar scene he got an eyebrow and why
couldn't she just watch her hair there
was just gelling it I don't know there
were a lot of things the eyebrow was
savage yeah but you know what that that
girl's really annoying and like I would
what I still would have done the same
thing to her luckily she's right but she
was an [ __ ] so we can't think like
that yeah and then the scene in the bar
with the dancing like and I also just
love and like Liz Gillies sings I know
she needs to do it more she they do like
really trying to incorporate as much as
possible without making it a musical and
Krystal grew on me everybody grew up me
watch their new crystal or old crystal
hmm I don't know
I love new crystal but I also love two
old crystal I really liked old crystal
too and I loved old crystal style me too
I'm not really here for a new crystal
style
yeah she's more of like a relaxed look
like laid-back like old crystal was more
of a businesswoman so she was always
wearing like cool pant suits yeah I'm
like she's just like savage it's like
I'm getting the vibe I like new crystal
like really isn't like here for like the
soccer team no but also in the beginning
of this season in the first episode
there was something shady when she was
back at her physical therapy thing like
it was looking like she was gonna plan
to get into this family like not that
she was the real crystal who met old
Chris right so like there's there's some
time the whole thing about M Jennings or
whatever right but I also really what
I'm here to talk about is Liam because
she came and she was trying to get Liam
back and like here's the thing I'm
almost positive that liam is endgame
here because like I do think that
they're probably gonna do what like the
audience wants because like why wouldn't
you and like I read Twitter like on the
live whatever and nobody likes calling
probably because he makes terrible
decisions and I truly can't stand him
but Liam said some things on this week's
episode that like you can't really take
back now and it's like how do you how do
you repair that and it's like I
understand right when she's ready for
him like it's not gonna be like that
easy like she's gonna have to work for
it totally I didn't expect for them to
like get back together right away there
would be no show but you're saying
there's no coming back from I don't know
he was like really really but I I
thought I mean he said some tough things
but he also said some true things like I
think what needs to happen his family
needs to go back to her roots of like
being a boss woman like starting she
needs some sort of business endeavor
she's not working right now technically
and that's so much of who he did fall in
love with and I think she needs to work
on herself and then maybe and they might
get back together or maybe it will be a
new person I agree no she definitely
like needs to get back to like business
being like you know badass [ __ ] and you
know on my Twitter true like strolling
even though I don't have a Twitter I was
looking at was her Twitter and she
responds to people's questions about it
and she was someone was like are we
getting business Liz back I mean that
one whatever same person and she was
like yes but she was like Fallon to ha
master
and she's like just trying to figure it
out which is true she's like dealing
with a lot of things and she's making
bad decisions and she's doing dumb
things I get it
so hopefully she just like comes through
it and she's just like even better than
ever and like I can't even I hope this
show never gets cancelled you don't
understand I love it it I think it's a
greatest thing that's ever happened to
us I agree especially the clothing and
just like all of it and like that it's
an Atlanta like it's just all that it's
just so cool it's so cool anyway so if
you need something to do this weekend I
heard there might be something going on
on Sunday but I just can't remember
definitely watch dynasty I wish I was
someone who had never seen dynasty made
for and I could enjoy it from the
beginning me too and like but where was
last season how it like how it started
it's just so like different from where
it is right now I think yeah I think I
would started you thought it was gonna
be like a little cheesy and stupid and
like it does take a few episodes to get
into I'll say the first four episodes I
was like really I'm and then can get out
some of the writing was a little cheesy
ER and like you know Fallon was just
like a [ __ ] and you don't like Fallon
at the beginning yeah and she like
didn't have really heart and so you were
like who am I even [ __ ] rooting for I
don't like these people right but then I
don't know if someone came in and gave
the show a little more heart and soul
I'm like direction and now I love
everyone me too like I love everyone
cept for Stephen yeh except he's I kind
of not really on the show and now he's
on in New York I know I thought he was
in LA I don't know and then also what's
her name
Colby sister is it Monique what is it
Oh sister yeah Mike I don't know she is
she'll never so I made a full oh I know
I know I like her except when she's
being mean to Fallon I just like I don't
know she rubs me the wrong way but yeah
I love her outfit honestly her name
someone with an M I know I'm not wrong
Monica Monica Nick Monica Monica that is
so funny um I loved her outfit I think
she's so beautiful and I loved when her
and fountain are good and I love that
they went we need to go to Sun Valley
where is it we're going I think it's an
Idaho I think it's an idea ho aiyah ho
ho well anyways
counselor snitch thank you so much for
hosting with me today you did such a
fabulous job thank you for bringing
really the you this perspective to the
show you too
you deserve
um we are back on Monday I will be
hosting with Darren so it'll be very
Bravo heavy oh I probably should have
waited to recap until Monday but you
know what it's guy you've been a guy I'm
sure there are people who didn't watch
takes a minute cuz you're on it yeah
they're anti snitch maybe you never know
and even though the Italian camera
obviously had to leave early so sad to
see her go maybe she'll pick me up later
maybe maybe you'll pick her up right
loving the Hat for you I guess I'm gonna
have to let you keep it now yes is that
okay yeah cuz you look so cute in your
your valve girl now and I can wear it
tomorrow I have a birthday tomorrow
night that I have to look at it I look
[ __ ] terrible for her girl who's
getting married in a few weeks like I
need to step up my game I don't know
what I look I look like I'm hosting the
[ __ ] SAG Awards that's how [ __ ]
saggy I look today no honestly say you
know and sometimes like well I didn't
have the patience to do my hair hence
I'm very happy for this but you know and
sometimes like your makeup just like
it's just not working for you and that's
kanita day and today I was feeling like
I just ordered a bunch of really cute
clothes and I haven't gone shopping for
like just like I've obviously gotten
topping but for like a bed so I'm always
getting a good new dress for this but
not for like this show and they actually
ordered some clothes recently and I'm
like waiting for them to come so it's
like until they do ever from fashion OVA
and shop up and I need I wanted to order
like some like tops like this you know
yeah I need to order some tops for this
show because I just look like a bag of
potatoes today a garbage bag full of
potatoes with like no bronzer on them
QT anyways bye guys we will see you on
Monday and on Monday we'll know who won
the Superbowl and so that will be crazy
go Pat's nation go Steen's nation by
follow us I Margar sure a body by snick
chopped up with no job
you